now coming out for art direction the war
to be presented by mark color
those nominated for the art-direction
awards are George Jenkins for all the
President's Men sets decoration by
George Gaines Elliot Scott and Norman
winners for the incredible Sava chain
Callahan and Chuck Hollis for the last
icon sets the equation by Jerry von
Dalek Dale Hennessy for Logan's one sets
the equation by orbit of Estelle Roberts
Boyle for The Shootist sets the equation
by Arthur Parker and the winners are
Church Jenkins for all the president's
men and for desecration charge games
I want to thank Robert Redford for
giving us this wonderful opportunity and
Alan Pakula oh yeah it was just terrific
as our director and very happy to have
had the opportunity to do it and all the
people who worked for us from the my
assistants the draftsman the carpenters
of painters and all the many men who put
it together I also want to thank all you
people who voted for me because I didn't
think destiny had an Oscar in store for
me my thanks to mr. Colvin mr. Redford
Mike and Gary and Tom and the Academy
thank you
the 49th Annual Academy Awards continues
now with Ellen Burstyn
in January I went to India and then I
took a little trip to Kathmandu and
while I was driving in the car my guide
asked me what I did for a living I said
I act he said oh yeah what movies have
you been in so I told him all the movies
I'd been in he hadn't heard of any of
him and Benny said well don't be
discouraged maybe someday you'll get
your big break and even win an Academy
Award I said oh is that so important
he's important well it's a it's a symbol
of achievement all over the world later
in the day we were walking down the
street and kept been doing a Buddhist
monk was walking toward us spinning a
prayer wheel and it was a warm day and
as he passed the air got very cool and
the guide said to me feeling a little
bit cool I said yeah what just happened
he said well he's from Tibet and he's
used to a cooler climate he was probably
feeling a little warm so he lowered the
temperature
I said now that's an achievement